one of the problems that we always have
is the kind of culture in which say
children involved it's hard to replicate
in our current in our current culture so
I always say sort of ideally what you'd
have is a 6 to 1 ratio where you could
have six grown-ups taking care of each
child and maybe a better way of putting
it is that you'd have a community of
parents you'd have a community of
caregivers the children are there as
part of that community it's not as if
anybody is sitting there and doing a
bunch of special things that are just
directed at the child so the vision that
we have from school there's someone
who's got this special responsibility of
shaping the education of the child is
the vision that is often imported into
being a parent so there's some special
set of things you should do some you
know flashcards or video or something
other than what you would normally do
that's the thing that you are supposed
to do to educate the child and what the
data the research shows is that children
are learning from just observing and
participating in the everyday things
that people are doing in an incredibly
subtle and powerful way so all the
conscious I mean the irony is that the
unconscious things that you do when
you're in when you're interacting with
children are much more likely to shape
and affect the way they think than any
of the things that you actually
consciously decide to do and I think we
have some lovely models for the way that
for example my personal favorite is
cooking so my grandchildren come in and
cook with me children love cooking they
love being involved in there's nothing
that seems more interesting to them than
an adult she's actually trying to do
something actually trying to bring
something about and integrating them
into that work so in a sense in in the
village the line between here's work and
here's children just wasn't there now
the question is what do we do now to try
to when that's no longer true we're no
longer growing up in a village what can
we do now to kind of recreate that
situation and I think the best
preschools essentially recreate
that village for children so what they
do is put children in a context with a
lot of adults who really care about them
who are who are warm who are supportive
and lots of stuff for them to play with
another thing another thing I say
sometimes it's you really wanted to know
what children preschool children young
children need to thrive they need mud
livestock and relatives and those are
things that are in sort of short supply
but we can try and say a a good
preschool to replace the mud livestock
in relatives with good teachers and
cocoons and caterpillars and sand boxes
but that's much more what young children
are learning for then although kind of
very scholastic academic activities that
parents feel as if they need to engage
in and I think that also makes life as a
working parent easier than if you think
that you have one job and then you have
another job to think that you have a job
and then you have this relationship this
kind of form of love that you have with
these children that you're engaged in
it's not the same thing as work part of
the trouble in our culture in our
society is that we measure everything we
treat everything as if it's either a
kind of production or a kind of
consumption so from that perspective
either having children is an extremely
badly paid job or else it's an extremely
expensive luxury and caregiving for
children and for people in general just
isn't a kind of production or a kind of
consumption
it's its own thing it's a deep important
part of being human beings that we make
these profound commitments to other
people we care about those people we do
what we can to let those people thrive
on their own terms and in their own way
that's a deep thing that we do
specifically about children but it's a
part of our relationships with spouses
it's a part of our relationships we say
our parents when they get older and we
have to take care of them and it's
something that's kind of invisible in
our culture at large because it doesn't
fit into the production bucket or the
consumption bucket one way to think
about it is instead of thinking about
parenting we should be thinking about
being a parent
and it's interesting that we don't you
know we don't why our husbands and we
don't friend our friends and we don't
child our parents we wouldn't measure
the quality of any of those
relationships by saying oh let's see is
my husband actually you know has he
achieved his benchmarks is he better
than he was when I married him
you work at relationships you put time
and energy into them but you don't think
of them as in this kind of shaping in
this kind of shaping process and one of
the things that makes caregiving so
interesting so much more interesting
than it is on the parenting model is
these deep tensions these kind of
paradoxes that come in caregiving where
we have to go from taking care of the
most dependent creature we know of a
human baby who completely requires us to
make decisions for them to to keep them
alive and the outcome of all that is to
try to create an adult who's completely
independent of us who's completely
autonomous who can make decisions
including making terrible decisions
independently of us in some sense if
your children don't have the potential
to fail then you haven't succeeded as a
parent because what you want to do as a
parent is make someone who's independent
on autonomous enough so they can take
risks and taking risks means the
possibility of failure that's a really
different that's a different kind of
activity then then almost any other kind
of human activity and it's deep and
profound and it's a big reason that
human beings have been able to succeed
as well as they have